As we head towards an epic face-off between
the Avengers and Thanos in Avengers: Infinity
War, it's crucial to keep track of what's
going on with the Infinity Stones, and Doctor
Strange's solo movie reveals an important
new piece in the infinity stone puzzle!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and I'm
going to talk about a cool infinity stone
reveal from Doctor Strange and give you a
full update on the status of all six Infinity
Stones in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Just so you're aware there will be spoilers
coming up for Doctor Strange, so if you haven't
seen the movie yet or want to avoid those,
click here for my spoiler-free movie review.
OK, let's first recap the key updates we get
in Doctor Strange about the Infinity Stones.
The movie reveals that the Eye of Agamotto
holds an infinity stone, the Time Stone in
fact.
As its name suggests, the Time Stone has the
power to manipulate the space-time continuum
and we first see this after Strange uses the
Eye of Agamotto to cast a spell where he moves
an apple backwards and forwards in time, from
whole to eaten and decayed and back to whole
again.
Strange even uses it to restore the stolen
pages from the Book of Cagliostro and there's
that sudden moment where columns of glass
or crystal shoot up in front of him, disappearing
as Wong and Mordo burst in and scold him for
the dangers of manipulating the space-time
continuum.
So, there's an interesting bit of foreshadowing
in this scene, with Mordo warning Strange
about getting stuck in a time loop, which
of course is the trick that Strange uses later
against Dormammu.
And the mirrored images that pop up suggest
Strange is peeking into visions of alternate
timelines.
By the way, even when time spells aren't being
cast, the movie plays on the theme of time
with lingering shots of Strange's collection
of expensive watches and with Strange asking
Dr West to cover his watch during an operation.
Later in the movie, Doctor Strange again opens
the Eye of Agamotto in Hong Kong, using the
time Stone to roll back significant events
in time, restoring demolished buildings and
even bringing Wong back to life.
And during his confrontation with Dormammu,
Strange also cheats death himself with the
creation of a time loop.
These scenes were visually very cool and impressive,
but the resurrection that the Time Stone seems
to allow has wider implications for the MCU.
For example, could it bring back a fallen
Avenger like Quicksilver?
Obviously, there are risks to using the Time
Stone.
Mordo is opposed to using it in the film as
it's against natural law, and his words "the
bill comes due" could be foreshadowing Thanos
getting hold of the Time Stone.
As Wong said, news of the Ancient One's death
will spread rapidly through the multiverse
and Thanos may also have detected Strange
using the stone in the Dark Dimension as we
know he's tracking where all the stones are.
By the way, talking of Mordo, going forward
keep a look-out for the Staff of the Living
Tribunal which Mordo mentioned when explaining
magical relics to Doctor Strange.
The Living Tribunal is a character in the
Marvel comic book multiverse with power that
eclipses even that of the Infinity Gauntlet,
and the way Mordo gave a special mention to
the Staff of the Living Tribunal could mean
we'll see this relic or the character come
into play in Infinity War.
So, now we've seen the Time Stone in action,
Wong and Strange have decided to leave the
Eye of Agamotto alone in a room that was already
broken into by Kaecilius and his Zealots.
If it stays there, it's not hard to imagine
how Thanos will get his hands on it!
And what about the other five stones?
Well, we've got four others accounted for
so far: the Space Stone, the Reality Stone,
the Power Stone, and the Mind Stone.
The Space stone, also known as the Tesseract,
can act as an energy source and also open
up portals in space to allow teleportation
between worlds.
It was harnessed by Red Skull in the first
Captain America movie, stolen from SHIELD
by Loki in The Avengers, and last seen being
taken back to Asgard by Thor at the end of
that movie and stored in Odin's Treasure Room.
But with Loki masquerading as Odin at the
end of Thor: The Dark World, could the stone
have already fallen into the wrong hands?
The Reality stone, aka the Aether, is extremely
powerful and was wielded by Malekith in Thor:
The Dark World.
The Aether takes on a liquid form rather than
a solid state, and Odin has said it can convert
matter into dark matter.
It's not completely clear yet what else it
can do, but it is extremely dangerous as it
reputedly has the power to destroy the whole
Universe.
Ironically, given he seems a pretty shady
character, it was handed over for safekeeping
to Taneleer Tivan, aka the Collector, at the
end of The Dark World, although events later
in Guardians of the Galaxy led to an explosion
at Tivan's collection, so it's unknown whether
the Aether is still in his possession.
And it was the Guardians of the Galaxy who
introduced the Power Stone, which Thanos had
ordered Ronan the Accuser to obtain for him.
The Power Stone, as its name suggests, is
incredibly powerful and can even destroy a
whole planet if it falls into the wrong hands.
It was handed over to the Nova Corps at the
end of Guardians of the Galaxy who put it
in their vault for supposed safekeeping.
In the comics, the Nova Corps derive much
of their power from the Nova Force which could
suggest the Nova Corps might try to harness
the energy from the Power Stone.
The Mind Stone has featured in both Avengers
movies so far, first brought to Earth by Loki
in his sceptre and used to mind-control Hawkeye.
After it fell into the hands of HYDRA, it
was used to harness the latent powers of Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver, and later when Tony
Stark recovered it, it was one of the elements
used to bring Vision to life.
And the Mind Stone is currently embedded in
Vision's forehead.
The stone we haven't yet seen, the Soul Stone,
will presumably show up in one of the films
before Avengers: Infinity War or in Infinity
War itself.
In the comics, the Soul Stone is sentient,
hungers for other souls and it has the power
over life and death, all of which mean it's
a good candidate for turning up in Thor: Ragnarok
which will introduce Cate Blanchett as the
supernatural villain Hela.
Hela is an Asgardian goddess, Queen of Hel
and has a history of stealing souls in the
comics, which could mean she either already
has the stone or knows where it is and is
going to steal it.
There was a scene from Hel teased in Thor's
vision in Avengers: Age of Ultron and Thor
also had a vision of the Infinity Stones which
he decided to investigate at the end of that
Avengers movie, all of which points to an
important infinity stone reveal in Thor: Ragnarok.
By the way, there's also a theory that Heimdall
possesses the Soul Stone, indicated by his
glowing orange eyes, and that the Stone can
be seen in his armour.
So guys, we now have the location of the Time
Stone in the MCU confirmed, but we're still
missing the Soul Stone.
What movie do you think it's going to show
up in?
And what are your predictions for how Thanos
is going to get hold of all six stones?
I always enjoy reading your thoughts in the
comments below.
If you liked this video and it's your first
time here, I'd love it if you'd subscribe
and you can also take a look at more of my
Marvel videos in my playlist right there.
Or check out my full guide to all the easter
eggs in Doctor Strange.
Click on the links below to check 'em out.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!